[Applause]
[Music]
1960 only 13 years after the Wright
brothers flew the first heavier than air
aircraft an American company was
established ready to revolutionize the
fledgling aviation industry founded as
Pacific Aero Products and renamed just a
year later as Boeing the company enjoyed
Decades of success and developed some of
the best Technologies and many of the
best aircraft of the time from a first
modern commercial airliner the Boeing
247 launched in 1933 to the iconic jumbo
747 Boeing was able to amaze humankind
for decades until Airbus came along that
is
90 years after the launch of the iconic
Boeing 247 the world of Aviation today
is radically different not only does
Boeing no longer lead the market it has
been overtaken by a competitor almost
half its age Airbus take a look at this
graph what you see is a hard-fought wall
a market divided by two giants where
Airbus is now in the lead and it has
been for most of the past 20 years
Europe's Airbus has recorded more orders
than its North American rival the
question is why how is it possible that
the Europeans have managed to beat the
mighty American Commercial aviation
industry many of you may be thinking
that this change has a lot to do with
the Boeing 737 Max Fiasco a plane that
was grounded for 20 months because air
safety authorities banned it from flying
after two fatal crashes and yes in a way
this has a lot to do with what happened
after all the 737 Max was Boeing's great
hope although we are not going to delve
too much into this matter because we've
already made a video entirely dedicated
to this topic here on visualpolitik and
I'll leave the link at the end of this
video but nope that's not the only
reason why Airbus has managed to
overtake its U.S rival in this case the
story goes back much further
[Music]
have you ever wondered how on Earth a
European Aircraft Company managed to
catch up in quality and Technology with
the Great American leader that
controlled this industry practically
from the start how did Airbus coming to
being whose idea was it and why was it
created and who put up the money to make
it look like a rival for Boeing and
perhaps the most important question of
all what on Earth does all of this have
to do with visualpolitik visualpolitik
viewers the story of Airbus and its war
with Boeing is more than a story of
competition between two companies it is
also a story of political competition
the United States versus the European
Union the old Giant versus the new Titan
and believe me when I tell you that
there are a lot and I'm in a lot of
layers in this story this is a story
that goes far beyond Aviation itself so
are you ready are your seat belts
fastened well let's get started
[Music]
strength
the second half of the 20th century was
the era of economic explosion and
modernity both in the west and in much
of Asia it was also the time when Europe
was rising from the ashes of World War
II where once there had been constant
fighting and conflict now suddenly there
was agreement and cooperation in fact if
this had not been the case Airbus would
probably never have existed
the European Aeronautics company par
Excellence was launched in 1970. it was
the result of a political negotiation
between governments that had already
begun a few years earlier yes that's
right Airbus was not the brainchild of
some Visionary entrepreneur or anything
like that the idea came from the offices
of the French and West German
governments in the late 1960s to achieve
this these governments encouraged the
union of the French aeronautical company
aerospatial with the German company
boycher Airbus the Consortium was later
joined by aeronautical companies from
Spain and the United Kingdom in essence
the idea was to replicate the
collaboration that the French and the
British had undertaken to create Concord
a few years earlier but in this case
with the objective of creating a
long-term structure that would make it
possible to make aircraft that were
shall we say less exclusive aircraft
that first had to be able to fill a gap
in which the American Boeing Lockheed
and McDonald Douglas which completed
about 80 of the market had no product
and later to compete with them directly
on a large scale and so it is that the
first aircraft to be launched was the
Airbus a300 which was the first
wide-body aircraft to make commercial
flights with two engines under e-top
standards but let's not get sidetracked
and let's get into the situation
[Music]
Europeans manufacturing modern aircraft
and gradually gaining more and more
market share thanks to the merger of
several companies Boeing had to do
something so in 1997 it tried to
replicate the model by acquiring its
direct us competitor McDonnell Douglas
however with this purchase the American
Giant inherited some of the company's
problems including economic and
corporate culture problems that would
sooner or later take their toll
be there as it may the fact is that the
era of what is perhaps the most
important and Powerful duopoly of all
had begun that of Aviation now let's not
go too fast this is an industry that
requires a lot of capital investment
that is to make it work you have to put
in a lot of money as you can imagine
designing developing and Manufacturing
aircraft is not exactly easy the
question is who was going to put up the
money to develop the technology that
would allow each of the two companies to
try to conquer the market for the first
time Boeing had a potential Giant in
front of it capable of looking at them
eye to eye but how exactly would they
compete how did the Europeans intend to
eclipse the US giant well you see let me
say it again in order to launch a new
program to create a new airplane two
things are needed above all the first is
money lots and lots of money but to give
you a clear idea of what we're talking
about let's take a concrete example
let's take a look at the case of Airbus
A380 the world's largest airliner which
was discontinued in March 2021 when the
last aircraft left of the factory well
take a look
the A380 program which includes the
entire development cycle from conceptual
idea to entry into service was initially
estimated in 2000 to cost about 11.3
billion dollars however estimates today
point to the development of this giant
of the Skies swallowing up more than 30
billion dollars
these are astronomical figures and keep
in mind the Airbus itself acknowledges
that the A380 has never made a profit
well it is not that it is not generated
profit but that billions of dollars were
lost along the way and this is where we
need to come to the second thing you
need to launch a new aircraft in
addition to money there obviously needs
to be sufficient demand given the
numbers involved poor forecasts could
turn the development of the new aircraft
into a disaster well right here we come
to the most controversial part of this
Jewel of titans the question is what has
Airbus done better than the American
from the point of view of many Americans
what Europe has done with Airbus is
nothing short of unfair competition a
situation that even provoked a trade war
between the United States and the
European Bloc take a look U.S and EU
agree to suspend Airbus Boeing trade
fate the 17-year trade fight is the
longest and most costly in the history
of the WTO U.S importers have paid more
than 1.1 billion dollars of tariffs
since the duties in the dispute took
effect in 2019 according to data from
U.S Customs and Border Protection now do
you want to know exactly what this
conflict is about and why it has
occurred has Airbus really grown thanks
to favored treatment from European
governments has this been a case of
unfair competition and what about the
United States well let's take a look
[Music]
war of egos
the trade dispute between the United
States and the European Union and
between Boeing and Airbus with the World
Trade Organization in the middle had one
very clear cause financing you see
Airbus the European aircraft
manufacturer has been receiving huge
amounts of public money since its
Inception to meet the costs of
developing new aircraft but let's look
at a few facts throughout the history of
the Consortium the governments of France
Germany the United Kingdom and Spain
later joined by others have injected a
ton of cash money in the form of both
direct subsidies and Loans at
artificially low interest rates or
directly without any Financial cost that
is without interest we're talking about
Aid that could exceed 15 billion dollars
but whose impact on the market could
According to some estimates be in the
region of 200 billion dollars all of
which logically works against Boeing in
the United States all this funding is
what is known as launch Aid and forms
one of the largest industrial policy
plans in Europe in recent decades
[Music]
basically the European States used these
tools to cover a significant part of the
cost of the development of the first
Airbus models such as the a300 or the
mid-sized aircraft family such as the
A320 which competes with the Boeing 737
the conflict arises because initially
the idea was that these subsidies would
be reduced until they disappeared as
Airbus matured in the market and also
because they would have to be repaid in
full as each program made a profit
[Music]
in other words the company was to be
supported with European taxpayers money
as it took off with the expectation of
returning a higher profit down the track
nice pun basically a typical industry
policy plan which I am sure many of you
would consider favorably after all
Airbus was a success and well you may
also think that it is better to devote
public resources to initiatives like
this one rather than to other types of
let's say more abstract less productive
causes of course there would be a lot to
say about this matter but this is more
of a topic for our sister Channel visual
economic
in any case as you can imagine the
Americans are not happy about it and
even less so if we take into account
that this financial aid didn't end up
disappearing nor has Airbus repaid the
totality of these loans Airbus in
dispute over 600 million dollars of
unpaid loans used to develop the A380
according to Reuters Airbus claims that
it would no longer need to repay
outstanding State loans on the A380
because governments had agreed to share
risk in the roughly 15 billion Euro
project as you can see these launch Apes
were so advantageous that they
apparently included a clause whereby if
the program went wrong the risk was
shared between the lenders that is
governments and the recipient Airbus in
other words both would share the losses
which by the way does not happen with
the profits in fact it's not like Airbus
is losing money yes the A380 program
went badly but the company is going from
strength to strength for example in 2022
this company posted a net profit that
means after tax of more than 4.2 billion
euros the best result in its entire
history despite this part of the losses
on the A380 program have been absorbed
by the European countries and to tell
you the truth I don't know if this makes
any sense but what is clear is that the
Americans don't like it one bit the
anger is Monumental both at Boeing
headquarters and among politicians in
Washington
in their view the Europeans have been
torpedoing their aircraft industry with
alleged illegal Aid and in fact the
World Trade Organization went so far as
to rule that such loans to Airbus
generated unfair competition so what can
I say they did have a point in order to
make peace with Washington and comply
with WTO guidelines European Union
France and Spain had to raise the
interest rates charged to Airbus for
loans linked to the launch of the a350
one of the European manufacturers new
flagship programs now then stop let's
put the brakes on before you tip the
scales in favor of one or the other wait
a bit because as we usually insist on
visualpolitik every story has at least
two versions and it's not exactly as if
the Americans have been behaving above
board not at all in fact we could even
say that the US government has bailed
Boeing out of a lot of trouble in recent
years and it has done so in a number of
different ways some by the way with
catastrophic consequences do you want to
know what exactly we are talking about
do you want to know what tricks the
Americans got up to well pay attention
yeah
foreign
bailouts under the table
we've already told you that Airbus has
received a lot of money from European
taxpayers debts that on many occasions
have been forgiven which has clearly
harmed Boeing in its competition with
Airbus but what about the Americans have
they stood by with their arms folded
well obviously not there are some
winners and losers in this story Boeing
has also been receiving billions of
dollars in U.S government funding and
for many huge sweetheart deals favorable
treatment which is reported to have come
at times from the U.S Federal Aviation
agency itself the until recently highly
respected FAA the agency in charge of
regulating and overseeing all activities
related to civil aviation and its safety
in the United States the question is how
did they do it well as you can see the
way the United States has and continues
to fund Boeing is through multi-billion
dollar military and Aerospace contracts
which many believe are awarded with
inflated prices in other words ads as a
kind of hidden subsidy in fact look at
the data Boeing's largest contractors
are none other than NASA the US
Department of Defense and the U.S
Department of Homeland Security in 2017
alone Boeing earned 23.4 billion dollars
in U.S government contracts according to
data compiled from the general Services
Administration and in fact in its
defense Airbus claims that the constant
and numerous contracts Boeing receives
from the U.S government and public
agencies are a way of subsidizing the
American Aviation Giant
but not only that there is also the
alleged favorable treatment by the FAA
that we've been telling you about a
moment ago take a look
FAA saw high risk of crashes but let
Boeing 737 Max keep flying the Boeing
737 Max crashes were the horrific
combination of a series of faulty
technical assumptions by Boeing's
Engineers a lack of transparency on the
part of Boeing's management and grossly
insufficient oversight by the FAA report
of transportation and infrastructure
Committee of the United States House of
Representatives
FAA and Boeing manipulated 737 Max tests
during recertification in fact all
indications are in addition to the money
that the United States injects into
Boeing every year through contracts it
was also helping the company by
providing it with certain laxity when it
comes to certifying its airplanes
specifically the case of the 737 Max
which was an aircraft that was designed
late and poorly to compete with the
Airbus A320 Neo which was launched
practically by surprise and against
which Boeing found itself out of the
market and unable to compete
[Applause]
if these suspicions are confirmed what
we can say is that the outcome was
tragic but hold on because we haven't
told you about tax incentives yet
Washington State repeals parole Boeing
tax break U.S hopes to avoid EU tariffs
the changes would remove the 40 savings
on business and occupation tax which
saved Boeing some 118 million dollars in
2018 based on published jetliner reviews
are these Provisions not public
subsidies that also harm free
competition and are they not favoritism
on the part of U.S administrations
towards Boeing well the truth is that
the World Trade Organization not only
ruled against Airbus it also ruled
against the Americans WTO rules U.S
failed to stop unfair tax break to
Boeing the U.S had not enforced an order
in 2012 to stop subsidies to the U.S
aircraft maker through Washington state
tax breaks the undue competitive
Advantage led to Lost sales of Airbus
A320 Neo and A320 seal single Isle
aircraft in five sales campaigns so what
can I say both Giants guilty of doing
the same thing but in different ways
this is a story in which there are
neither Good Guys nor bad guys but at
the ground level there are big suckers
the taxpayers because yes it may be
reasonable to support the development of
a large technological and Industrial
projects so perhaps the aid should be
fairer limited and open to more
companies don't you think the fact is
that signing a trade peace agreement on
this issue between the United States and
Europe has not been easy nor has it been
something that fell from the sky what's
more there has been one factor that has
played a key role in the end of the war
between the two companies and the two
blocks can you guess what it could be
well listen up
[Music]
thank you
what Shayna has joined together let no
man put asunder
17 years of war between the world's two
leading aircraft companies takes its
toll in the end it's something we repeat
a lot on visualpolitik trade Wars don't
usually benefit either side and the case
of Boeing an Airbus is no different both
manufacturers have been hurting each
other and by extension may have been
hurting the development of the industry
the fight between the United States and
the European Union raised Import and
Export costs restricted the use and
development of Technologies and
ultimately made aircraft more expensive
and slowed the evolution of the industry
and you know what this created an ideal
breeding ground for others to try to
take advantage of the troubled waters
now the warfed ears are in View and yes
the wharf is once again China we also
agreed to work together the EU and the
US to challenge encounter China's
non-market practices in this sector that
give China's companies an unfair
Advantage as we also told you in a past
video in our dedicated series of videos
on the world of Aviation the Airbus
Boeing duopoly could be threatened at
least in the short and medium-haul
segment by a new competitor China's
comac
Beijing is aggressively using a mix of
the two forms of public subsidies we
have seen in this video those used by
the Europeans and those used by the
Americans the Chinese government is
directly subsidizing aircraft
development and is also placing huge
orders through its state-owned Airlines
in fact the comac
arj21 which can carry up to 100
passengers is already flying
commercially and the comac c919 is
currently on test flights although it
has encountered some problems and its
entry into service may be delayed from
the 2023 schedule the fact remains that
this aircraft May pose a huge threat to
the future of Boeing and Airbus we're
talking about an aircraft that can carry
up to 174 passengers and therefore
competes directly with the A320 and 737
in China the flagships of two Western
Giants what's more China expects to
manufacture 150 of these aircraft per
year by 2028.
and this scenario that of an aircraft
manufacturer for the Chinese short and
medium Hall Market would be the worst
nightmare for Airbus and birming why
because China is the key market for the
future of the two Aviation Giants in
fact according to Boeing's own
calculations the Asian Giants will need
to buy wait for it almost 8 500 new
passenger aircraft between now and 2041.
this is a real Payday and if a local
competitor such as comac manages to take
even a significant slice of this pie the
future of Boeing and Airbus could change
completely a direct hit to the business
so both companies and the governments of
the United States and the European Union
have been pragmatic in recent years both
companies have opened final assembly
lines in China for some of their most
sought after models such as the Boeing
737 or the Airbus A320 and a321 Neo in
addition European Union has suggested
that the United States that they will
end the so-called launch Aid to Airbus
in exchange for financing the Consortium
through military spending something we
are already seeing check it out spin to
lend Airbus 2.14 billion euros for
military programs yes as many of you may
be thinking this is practically adopting
the American model of financing Boeing
that Brussels has been fighting against
for 17 years well it's not exactly
unheard of for European politicians to
change their tune
what is known so far is that both blocks
the EU and the US have signed a truce a
ceasefire in this trade War which in
theory should be resolved before 2026
the future well we can't know for sure
but what is clear is that neither Airbus
nor Boeing is in a position to complain
too much about unfair competition the
two industrial Giants have received
enormous amounts of money both control
more or less a similar share of the
market and both have enormous political
connections with the public sector but
now it's your turn do you think Airbus
and Boeing will make peace for good
should the two companies start working
together to prevent the Chinese from
Gaining a foothold in the market what do
you think the war for control of the
Skies may look like in the cunning
decades leave us your thoughts in the
comments remember that if you also like
what we do you can support us by joining
our community in patreon in one of the
six different options that we have once
again thank you very much for being
there all the best I'll see you next
time
foreign